how you know because I I think about
Memphis and I think about
um you know when you from the time you
first came in obviously there was CMG
and Dolph and yourself and key Glock but
now it's like Memphis is truly at the
flower of hip-hop it's like a Powerhouse
everyone's stealing y'all slang
everyone's using y'all's producers just
is what it is Memphis got the [ __ ] sewed
up right now shout out to glorilla shout
out to him hey people for that aren't
from Memphis are even saying music
instead of music
you know
um but with that being said uh there's
always been a high level of negativity
associated with the scene there and I
feel like
at least with the bigger guys it feels
like it's getting past that like
um how did you break through like not
kind of getting wrapped up in a lot of
the Memphis politics
um just being able to want to spark
change you know
um lead by example show something
different I didn't I always didn't want
to be the norm I know God created me to
blaze a trail of my own or create a land
for other people
um to give other people options
um so coming up I knew like
I looked up to Gotti Dolph because I
feel like those were the two biggest at
the city growing up of course so with
that being said I took heed of stuff
they done Dolph had paper out yep got it
had CMG and I looked at it as if
I would never want to sign to these guys
but I would want to create my own Empire
like how they did it and um I feel like
this one I'm in the works are doing
um just giving that other route that
other option to the people from the city
and um I feel like I'm doing damn good
doing it you know I got four artists I
got a producer that's crazy just getting
a lot of a lot of blessed placements
right now so you know what I'm saying
it's a beautiful journey and probably 10
10 years from now five years from now
maybe even three in that League can be
one of those big Powerhouse labels
that's out of Memphis Tennessee I see it
happening too man